we for the second time today we're gonna
have a walk-on on set while we are live
on the air aj epinessa from
iowa here he is come on up have a seat
we just saw you on the podium a little
bit ago how's it going good good to see
you man have a seat and off we go
all right uh how's it going so far for
you it's good it's been a lot of fun
yeah i mean it's really kind of what i
expected
anything about the week that has been
like man i really didn't expect this
you know not really i kind of um i was
prepared well um
it's long days uh short nights waking up
early mornings
but i mean it's kind of a free-for-all
in those informal meetings where um
coaches are trying to come pick you up
um you have a formal meeting you just
kind of have to know your schedule and
they've i mean obviously they
accommodate really well with our have
given us our schedules but um you have
to be able to be on top of it it's all
about um being responsible and just
showing up where you need to be on time
who prepared you for what to expect and
how it's all going to unfold here um my
agency helped me a lot with a lot of
preparation stuff
my agent is patrick collins um and i
work with caa
but um
they did a lot of preparation stuff
trying to help get me ready get me
prepared for this and um i think it's
it's uh helping out really a lot play a
little basketball yeah thousand points
in high school
when did you realize that football was
the better path for you
oh when i first started playing football
i remember
fourth grade playing uh peewee football
and we did our first tackling drill and
i was nervous because i had never
tackled anybody before it's my first
time
um and it just kind of came naturally
just tackling people i mean it's
something i just love doing and um i
picked it up real quick and it's just i
love it ever since do you remember the
name of the kid you tackled the first
time oh it was one of my childhood
buddies i i don't remember his name
exactly but i'm still good friends with
all my peewee football friends because
we played all the way through middle
school and through high school it
started all the way from fourth grade
and went through senior year so i mean i
know all of them but i couldn't tell you
exactly who it was when did you know
that you were going to be good enough to
make it to the nfl level
i never really knew that until probably
this year because i went into high
school never really expecting i never
anticipated like college letters and
scouts and stuff like that or being a
five star and so like i never
assumed that was going to happen i just
kind of my i remember my first letter
um after my freshman season was from uh
florida state and i had gotten hurt that
year and um missed a couple games
um as a freshman and i was kind of like
why do i have this letter i didn't
really expect it to be like that did
they send it the wrong person yeah
that's what baseball sounds like this is
mine right
but um
i i kind of went i went to a nike camp
and stuff like that and i started to get
more exposure and recruiting started to
blow up a little bit and then kind of
same thing with college i came in just
trying to start get playing time that
was my goal and i've never really
considered the nfl and it's just kind of
growing into what it is now but i think
that's credit to me just kind of
trusting the process no matter what
level i've been at just kind of doing
what needs to be done and doing the best
i can at it that's the right attitude
you know you do the best you can with
the abilities you have and everything
else takes care of itself and if it's
meant to be it's meant to be but all you
can do is do the most with what you're
given and obviously you've done enough
to get yourself on the brink of being in
the nfl yeah where'd you go to high
school what was the name of the school
editorsville high school in southern
illinois all right and we've got some
highlights
a.j eppinessa from high school and
usually it's the guy who stands out as
the dominant player that we are looking
at and there it is you threw the
quarterback about
what do you remember from some of these
games well give me this um i remember
everything this is my freshman year
against uh east st louis
this is uh yeah i'm 14 years old
freshman year against um east st louis
high school southern illinois
yeah and and you didn't realize at that
age you were destined for the nfl are
you kidding me or for college no
dominant as a as a freshman no i did
three-time all-state as well what did
you did you play offense you go both
ways i played some tight end yeah yeah
do you want to catch the football a
little bit in uh at the next level i
mean if they want me to score some
touchdowns i'm not going to tell them no
did you do any tight end work at iowa um
i caught a fake fake field goal um so i
wasn't really ever like an offensive
tight end but i'm on on field goal i was
there and had the opportunity to catch
fakes you also have the ability to throw
the discus two-time state discus
champion when did you recognize you had
that skill
it's not until high school my uh head
football coach uh matt martin at
everestville high school um
he was my head football coach he was my
d-line coach and he was my throws coach
um and he basically convinced me to come
through and i never really considered
because i didn't do it in middle school
i only ran
and i was expecting to only run in high
school
but he kind of talked me into throwing
and it's something i grew into and
something i really wasn't all that good
at i think i was just naturally raw at
it freshman year but technique started
to set in
um as the years went on and um i got i
got obviously better at it and it's just
kind of i mean
it's something i really enjoy and worfs
you know worfs can throw the shot put
eight miles and he he uh i think we were
talking to him yesterday they couldn't
play tennis in the tennis courts when he
threw the disc because there was a
chance it was going to go off track yeah
was there anybody that had to take cover
when you were around throwing the discus
no our our setup was just a huge open
field so i couldn't even hit anybody if
i tried over there um did you try
yeah i mean it was i mean i could try i
hit i did hit a kid one time um
he didn't like he was out there shagging
like he was going to do the measurements
and bringing the disc back like we were
at a away meet and so they're kind of
being a it's a common courtesy at a home
like your guys come and they get the
stuff for the other people and um it was
a wet day out and my disc hydroplaned
and hit him right in the shin
and he started bleeding and they had to
he had to go right to the emergency room
how to get stitches that day
who there's no transition you can make
from that who at the nfl level
when you go out on the field and we've
been asking everybody this who is the
guy that is going to make you just freak
out and say i can't believe i'm on the
same field as this guy
i mean there are so many i mean
there's so many
you know i mean if i if i were to be on
the falcons
um adrian claiborne would be one just
because he was an iowa legend he was the
94 before me
um and i've met him before but being
able to work with him would be something
that would be
amazing he was the first rounder back in
2011 with the buccaneers he's been with
the patriots a little bit with the
falcons and he he's had some moments
where he's he's been elite level pass
rusher that just i think it's injuries
and consistency that hasn't been there
that's a good guy to look up to who's
the quarterback you want to sack the
most
i never think i thought about that all
that much i just wanted to i just like
sacking all the quarterbacks any of them
whoever has the ball yeah you treat him
like you treated the guy from east st
louis when it was first and goal on the
five and he ended up at the 20. that's
what you wanted to all of them right all
right well hey aj congratulations on
your success enjoy the week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports